so the new trailer for Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania is now out and in
this video we're going to be doing a big
breakdown to discuss the movie all the
hidden details in the teaser Easter eggs
and things you missed I also want to
talk about some plot leaks and this will
explain why Janet fears the quantum
realm and her relationship with Kang I
won't however spoil the ending of the
movie without giving you a big warning
and as always these leaks might not even
be accurate so take him with a pinch of
salt now who here is like after all why
not
why should I read the plot leaks it's
also about 4am in the morning here in
the UK so the thumbs up it's massively
appreciated and let's get into the video
[Music]
you're an interesting man
Scotland
[Applause]
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me
we can help each other with that
who are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
time now the trailer opens with a shot
of San Francisco this is of course a
location where the last two Ant-Man
movies took place and it's also the city
where shangchi started we'll talk about
this later on in the video but there's
lots of links to the eternals naga bands
and the 10 Rings possibly tying those
movies together for the next phase in
the MCU Kang says it's got an
interesting man and his narration
dominates the entire trailer really
giving the idea that he's a major force
to be reckoned with in this movie and
from here we see Scott and Hope on the
red carpet showing how they've gone from
being on the run in Civil War to now
being widely admired by the people of
the MCU the MCU has been littered with
clues that Scott has cashed in on the
fame that came with him helping to save
the universe Humanity was at its lowest
point after the snap and for five years
the world wallowed an oppression over
the ones they lost the anxiety of how
fragile our lives were we know from
Hayward in one division that these times
were dark and even the best heroes like
Hawkeye became cruel Vigilantes Scott
returned from the quantum Realm and it
was his return that ushered in the time
travel plot that held to save the
universe so man's a big name now and Ms
Marvel opened with an odd to his podcast
big me little me wakanda forever also
promoted his book on the news ticker
which we know is called look out for the
little guy this book will pop in the
movie with Scott doing a reading for it
and how greatness comes from little
things just tell your girl that you're
loser now he's basically gonna be the
person that cashed in on the troll map
and he's used the Public's interest to
catapult his profile if you've seen The
Haunting of Hill House and you know a
character in that did something similar
this caused issues with a family and
also his friends you of course have
already seen the Baskin and Robin's
employee of the century photo and along
with managerdale returning we saw
Scott's uniform in a glass case it was
also his employee photo and this had the
name Jack on his name badge now we know
the name Jack was picked because it's
the same one as Paul Rudd's son and
we'll talk about how this movie is about
parents and the relationships that they
have with their children now we of
course men adult Cassie end game and
she's gonna be taking more of a role
than she has in previous films she's
sort of going to be reflecting how Scott
was before he became a superhero and
will have been in prison for doing Robin
hoodesque deeds and helping out the poor
Scott of course did this and he carried
out crimes against corporations that
were extorting people that's sort of the
same thing with Cassie he'll be a hero
in her own way whilst her father
galavants about the catwalks bragging
about how he's won as he completely
ignores causes that he doesn't think
will benefit him now this movie is very
much going to be about the pair
connecting after having grown slightly
estranged since the events of endgame
the first two Ant-Man films Scott wanted
nothing more than to have time with her
and she was the first person he went to
after coming back from the quantum realm
a judging by this new look it seems like
Kang will be offering Scott more time
with his daughter in a reality where
Thanos maybe never carried out the Snap
we know that these exist due to the
Multiverse of Madness which show that
the Illuminati were able to defeat
Thanos before he could carry it out thus
their world was far more advanced in the
616 and the planet was also protected by
ultrambots which likely stopped the
majority of crime it seemed way more
like Utopia and Kang could offer Scott a
world where he can live with his
daughter without having to be an Avenger
or having lost those five years she of
course also deals with a lot of trauma
because of those five years it looks
like she's gonna have to wrestle with
the idea of potentially losing Scott
again here now the quantum realm device
has actually had some info shared on it
from what we know about the trailer that
was shown at Comic-Con this contained a
lot of extra shots that haven't been
shown yet and had Cassie talking about
the device itself turns out she actually
made this during the five years between
the snap and the blip as a way to try
and rescue her father I don't know how
she knew he was in the quantum realm but
from the Comic-Con event we know that's
why it was created that backstage scene
had it talking about how she made it
with a partner and as it's not with
hanker Janet and it might be with
someone like ghost or even Bill Foster
he used to be Goliath he was helping
ghost and after losing her father he
might have turned his attention to
Cassie the orb glows blue and it's
possible it was created by Kang and that
this was sent to Cassie which is why it
looks similar to the orbs on the shape
that we see later as pot of Kang's
forces McCarthy is going to be getting
her own suit too and it's likely that
she'll be going under the name Stinger
she was known as stature at one point in
the comics but the name Stinger keeps it
more in line with Ant-Man and the WASP
she's also gonna get captured by Kang 2
and then held hostage that her father
helps her out
[Music]
can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Applause]
he can give us a second chance
[Music]
let me make this easy for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life
will end a drought Kang's very much
acting like someone who can give Scott
what he wants but in order to do this
he's gonna have to do something very bad
he who remains was very much thought of
as being the devil and due to this deal
Kang Echoes at two even the entire thing
with Kang here is based around the idea
that he's the ruler of the underworld
and this hammers harm the notion that
the entire thing's a deal with the devil
he carries demonic imagery like his
glowing eyes and he has powers that can
far match anything that mortal men can
throw at him the orange Portal 2 is
almost like a fire and there's
definitely this notion that he's trying
to escape hell this is obviously taking
him into other realities but I think
it's an important bit of symbolism Scott
doesn't really care though as he's more
bothered about his daughter than the
rest of the Multiverse there's
definitely this idea of the needs of the
few and how helping Kang could destroy
all reality which is why Scott's been
selected he is one of the only people
that can help Kang and he's in a
precarious position because his daughter
is the one in danger Ant-Man isn't the
type of person to make sacrifices and
this is of course also why the Avengers
lost a Thanos in Infinity War he also
just wants those five years back and
again this could lead itself to Kang
possibly offering a better life the
deleted scenes for Loki season 1 had he
who remains doing something similar with
there apparently being moments where
we'd see Loki in salvi being offered
realities where they had all their
hearts desired a Kang's costume looks so
good and I know a lot of it was shown in
the first trailer but seeing how much
they've nailed it really fills me with a
lot of confidence Kang could have easily
been a weird looking villain and he's
one of those characters that I saw years
ago in the comics and thought it would
be so difficult to pull this off but
they've managed to do it Kang's mask is
a big thing with a blue face cover
almost being like a visor in the film
The Comics have had a number of
different materials for this and in the
recent graphic novel only myself left to
conquer we see different versions of him
most MCU masks these days they just wrap
around someone's head after coming out
the back of the costume and I think a
similar thing is gonna be happening here
you've also seen this shade of blue
before in the MCU and I might be
reaching but it reminds me a lot of
devices that we used on the quantum
suits in endgame now time for a joke
what what do they call it when a bunch
of Kang variants all sleep with the same
person at the same time a Kang bang
thanks a mirror week anyway this suit
needs to be heavily armalized because
Kang is going on vast Journeys through
the Multiverse and into other realities
Multiverse of Madness showed us there
were some environments like the paint
world and that he needs to be prepared
for anything therefore it's sort of like
an astronaut suit and no matter what he
encounters he's prepared for the
environment the quantum realm itself is
also really unstable and in the skyline
you can see these massive holes in
almost portal-like structures these look
a lot like the tunnels that were in the
realm when the Avengers dive down into
it and potentially these could allow
Kang to travel into other worlds and
through time now over the top of this we
can hear Janet talking about how he can
rewrite existence Shadow timelines hit
the sub subscribe button and that he
basically can't be trusted the plot
leagues have kind of filled in the
details with this and though they might
not be correct they've said they go way
back they state that when she landed in
the quantum realm that she wandered
through the Wilderness and made a home
down there one night she saw a ship
crashing which is possibly shown in the
clip where we see a hooded figure
looking at something crashing down from
the sky she's then meant to be chased by
some creatures before Kang saves her and
this is how they meet now these
creatures were potentially shown on the
first trailer with Janet standing on a
rocky platform whilst a monster closes
in on her either way Kang will be
someone like her who's stuck down there
and the pair will work together in order
to fix his ship we'll apparently hear
his name Nathaniel and they'll spend a
lot of time getting to know each other
during this time Janet will discover his
true plans and will learn that he has a
ship which can travel across the
Multiverse Kang will have conquered
several realities at this point and
he'll very much be ushering in the
prophecy that he who remains warned Loki
about in case you don't remember he said
that he discovered covered multiversal
travel early on in his life and this
allowed him to open gateways to other
worlds here he met versions of himself
across the Multiverse however with an
infinite amount of people that were good
there were also versions of him who were
completely evil because of the power
they'd unlocked they realized they had a
way to travel across multiple Realms and
conquer them across the Multiverse this
led to all-out war between realities in
which several timelines fought it out so
that they could have dominance judging
by the rumors on Secret Wars this will
also be what plays out in that movie
with several timelines fighting against
a supreme version of Kang in order to
stop him taking over everything a he who
remains managed to defeat the evil kangs
and because of this he decided to form
the TVA which would stop offshoot
realities by wiping them out this would
stop the possibility that a version of
him could be born that would want to
destroy the Multiverse with he who
remains dead the mcu's now in a stay
where can can once more rise up allowing
this one ship to be fixed could assure
in the end of all worlds Shannon
apparently ended up sabotaging his ship
upon learning this and she fled leaving
him stuck in the quantum realm for
decades plotting his revenge now there
was a line in the first trailer where
Kang said that he'd help someone get
home and give them more time
and give you more time
if you help me
so
What's it gonna be
[Music]
this was presented in a way in which it
was aimed at Scott as an exchange for
helping him out but it is possible that
it could actually be Janet she's been
stuck in the quantum realm and has lost
out on decades with her daughter either
way Kang wants Scott to help him out and
this is likely the key to starting a
ship at once more so he can travel a
Multiverse again in that time you start
up chronopolis and has made a
civilization down there that's also got
warring factions against it this is the
rebels who all seem like new characters
whether there is one that seems like
Acro yeah though it might just be a
design similarity Kang has his pythians
though who are in the comics and their
forces that fight for him and resemble
how the villain looks now they are
escorted by some of these in the trailer
and we can also see my boy mode
foreign
[Applause]
has been heavily hidden from the
marketing but little leaks have made
their way to the surface and according
to early reports he'll be an evolution
of Darren cross cross Was Defeated at
the end of Ant-Man and as he was sucked
into the quantum realm his body
distorted due to the suit malfunctioning
after Scott broke it this is why the
proportions are all wrong and it's a
nice way to explain why he's this way in
the MCU in the comics the character
George Tarleton has had a number of
different reasons as to why his bodies
grew the way that it did with it being
sometimes down to disease and sometimes
because he grew his brain too big
Murdoch has a distinctive look and sure
it's goofy yeah but that's that's what
also makes him so memorable you'll never
forget this guy when you assume if you
want to support the channel and get some
cool merch out of it we've just launched
this Ant-Man Size Matters t-shirt which
will be linked in the pin comment and
also the description case you don't know
me Greg from real Rejects and ryanairy
bloody blue ryanairy start up a company
called hero Edition that sells merge
from all our channels spent ages making
sure the material is top quality the
shirts are all unique and it helps us
make videos like this mediocre one
you're watching right now each one is
part of a limited run though so once
it's gone it's gone you punk make sure
you make sure you go whilst it's still
hot and from here we get some expanded
shots of what we've seen with Janna and
Co before riding on top of that Stingray
looking creature however Beyond this we
also get a large golden ring structure
that carries special glyphs on it these
have slowly been popping up in the MCU
at several points and as always it could
it could be connected
now the glyphs appeared in the Eternal
ship and they were also sewing out shut
up on the 10 rings as well as the bands
in Ms Marvel and I'm not the first
person to point this out and I think
Ryan Airy shut the [ __ ] up Ryan Airy
bloody Ryan area I think he did a full
video talking about them
these might just be Marvel giving nods
to their greater universe or there could
be a reason that they've chosen these
devices because they're all linked
together shangshi of course ended with a
beacon being found and it's possible
that this came from the quantum realm
rather Ming something out in Space the
Naga bands could also open doorways to
other realities and they gave someone
the ability to travel through time which
if linked with chronopolis could explain
how all this stuff happens now Scott
clearly goes in a further part of the
quantum realm and he runs into what
could be variants of himself we see
several Scots forming a column and this
is of course also similar to how ants
operate this is all seemingly to grab
what I think's a battery which will
likely help power the ships so that Kang
can travel through the Multiverse
it's all my fault
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
you thought you could win
I don't have to win
I'm sorry Cassie
now according to rumors on the film we
will be traveling to the quantum Nexus
which is a place that exists at the
center of the quantum realm this is an
extremely dangerous environment in which
all of time and space blend into one and
the rules of reality are thrown out in
the plot leak set drop before the
trailer released it said that Scott
would go there for Kang and then he'd
come across different versions of
himself like I said this was dropped
before the first trailer and seeing that
made me think it's real with this
breaching across all different realities
the Ant-Man that we see here might even
be on the same Mission by alternate
kangs from alternate realities I think
that's what makes the most sense and
they're all going to be meeting at this
convergence point in order to get the
one item for their specific Kang as we
know several kangs are across the
Multiverse all Fang for Supremacy and I
love the idea that there's an infinite
amount out there and they're all after
the same thing so that they can beat the
others little detail you might have
noticed and Scott is that a second
version of him seems to come out of the
back of his head if this is a Nexus then
that could mean that's a literal point
at which reality splits often at other
timelines if you think about how a
timeline splits then there has to be a
point deep down in the fabric of
everything where it branches off this
would have to happen on a Quantum level
so this could be the point where
everything splits off this would explain
why Scott keeps splitting though they
could be Echoes and not variants a bit
confused but that's just my big dude
and we of course also get the giant
Ant-Man splitting off into ribbons it is
similar effect we've seen twice in the
MCU now with it happening to mantis in
Infinity war and Reed Richardson
Multiverse of Madness these were both
linked to reality with the reality Stone
changing mantis and wonders reality
warping Powers being the things that
turned Reed into Mom's spaghetti should
have called it the a38 mile Universe now
anyway that's gonna be a big location
that could have multiple antmen and
maybe even some realities where the WASP
went there instead and this would
explain why we see multiple wasps and I
know I'm clutching a theory time here
but it's a possibility I thought when
looking at the trailer at four in the
morning bear in mind it is possible that
Scott learns how to split reality and
that he can create Echoes of himself
this would be the ones that come out and
they're almost similar how ghost moves
potentially tying the two characters
together these would stop them being
variants that we see here and instead
they'd just be versions of him rather
than those from across the Multiverse
anyway Kang threatens that he will
destroy try everything Scott calls to
life you also get the text to witness
the beginning popping up on screen which
is a big thing as this is of course
really the start of Kang's rise to power
this is all gonna culminate in Kang
Dynasty and finally finish up with
Avengers Secret Wars either way we get a
lot of fight scenes at this point with
Kang clearly betraying Scott in this
deal and has also seen that Scott's
willing to lose in order to stop him we
also see Scott falling in the column
interspersed with this and I'm guessing
that he's saved by the WASP who comes
flying in he's the only one who isn't
wearing a helmet to keep things simple
and so that we can focus on him instead
of getting lost anyway in the end it
seems like Kang's gonna win and it sets
a very downward tone for the entire
movie this is ant-man's third film and
if we look back at the MCU several of
the third films in a Trilogy often close
out with a hero very much losing a part
of what made them and what I mean by
that is that Iron Man 3 ended with Tony
throwing away the Arc Reactor after
finding a way to live without it cap
ended up leaving the approval of the US
Government after Civil War until Thor
Ragnarok had Asgard being destroyed
Brant man there are a number of things
he could lose and now I don't think it's
gonna be his daughter it could be along
the lines of Hank hope or something else
being taken away from him anyway that
closes out the trailer very dark very
flashy looks wild and yeah I'm excited
for it and for the next part of the
video I want to talk about how the movie
ends according to the plot leaks because
of that big big big spoiler alert for
the next part of the video I told you
spoiler alert
the movie will apparently end with help
in Scott being trapped in the quantum
realm after Kang leaves them down there
before he flees to another world he'll
promise Janet in the movie that he'll
destroy every World across the
Multiverse before finally coming for the
616 last this will sort of set up the
events of Kang Dynasty and also Secret
Wars he'll come back from his quest with
several of the worlds destroyed and that
will end the movie with him having
ruined multiple realities and it will be
a final stand for all those affected by
coming to take the villain down the
kangu metier will be the final one they
face down against with he who remains
being all who remains on the other side
anyway that wraps up the video and I
hope you enjoyed the breakdown this will
probably be the final trailer as Marvel
tend to just do two trailers and then
they do multiple TV spots I'll try and
cover them too but I'm a busy guy and
but hopefully I see you back at the
channel when we do our breakdown on the
film The Answer mail is to watch we've
got a video on screen right now for you
telling it for you you're gonna bloody
love it I don't know why are you still
here get yourself over have a good have
a good day as well yeah take care
yourself mate peace